Donc on passe à l'évaluation pour les diakonas.
Et donc avant de rentrer dans cette section, juste pour faire un exercice.
Quelles seraient les aires de l'église où vous notez par exemple un besoin réglé,
une opportunité d'amélioration,
quelques aspirations très pratiques qui pourraient maximiser les ministères de l'église,
pour la croissance de l'église, pour aider les pasteurs.
J'avais un exemple en tête.
Oui.
Dans le ministère d'accueil, quand on a des visiteurs qui viennent pour la première fois,
on pourrait avoir déjà fait une réponse à une bible, la bible à 2 euros là.
Et on pourrait concevoir des petits marque-pages EDN avec les infos pratiques de l'église,
pour remettre à des visiteurs qui viennent la première fois.
Super.
Oui.
Un petit cadeau visiteur.
Parfait.
Oui.
Ça c'est l'une des expériences qu'on a quand on visite les églises qui sont un peu plus structurées et développées.
C'est vraiment, c'est pas forcément nécessaire.
Le plus important c'est l'accueil chaleureux qu'on fait et on fait bien.
Mais c'est clair que ces choses peuvent représenter, voilà, un empressement, un amour, un sens d'excellence encore plus grand.
Dans le même sens, quand j'étais au rédition, on a dit des églises aussi,
c'est une chose qui a fait quelques temps de l'accrocher.
Donc c'est que j'aime aussi la taille et la façon dont nous sommes disposés.
C'est que le pasteur, il partait, on va dire, à la fin du clip, pour pouvoir s'amener justement les visites.
Donc c'est que si les visites sont tout au fond, juste arriver au pasteur, c'est un peu 30 ans,
et que le pasteur, c'est à la fin, dans la partie, il peut envisager un peu plus de temps et interagir avec plus de monde.
Oui.
Ça, à un moment donné, c'était vraiment notre intentionnalité, sauf que l'espace dans lequel on est aujourd'hui,
ça ne prête pas à ça, car les passages vers l'escalier, il est très serré,
et ce n'est pas du tout confortable de développer des conversations dans cette dynamique.
Peut-être qu'on pourrait faire une annonce en disant aux personnes qu'ils sont bienvenues pour échanger avec les pasteurs,
qu'ils seront devant en attendant.
Mais c'est important, ça fait une partie de la tradition baptiste,
que les pasteurs soient toujours disponibles pour saluer tous les membres,
pas que les visiteurs, mais particulièrement les visiteurs.
Et si je fais ça, c'est un peu comme ça.
Et aussi, à la fin du tout, normalement, c'est une grande relation qui prend des noms,
donc le pasteur va arriver à pied,
et voilà, pas forcément important,
c'est-à-dire, voilà, nous sommes contents,
et vous prenez que vous êtes venus,
pour la prochaine fois, les visiteurs.
Ça, je ne suis pas très appréciatif.
C'est assez particulier de les nommer.
À mon avis, je pense qu'il faut respecter les moments de recherche volontaire de Dieu que chacun a.
Parfois, la personne préfère, dans leur premier contact avec l'Église,
de rester un peu anonyme.
Il faut qu'on sache respecter ça.
Il faut que tout soit vraiment authentique,
mais il faut qu'ils sachent que nous sommes à disposition,
et que nous chérissons leur présence.
Donc, je pense que c'est suffisant, rien que par les interactions qu'on fait.
Je n'aime pas trop, en fait,
quand on essaie de prendre leur nom très vite,
leur contact, etc.
Donc, s'ils veulent le faire,
il faut qu'il y ait des moyens accessibles pour qu'ils le fassent,
qu'ils soient communiqués.
Mais voilà, c'est juste des convictions personnelles que j'ai pour ça.
Et les anciens, on y allait voir, les visiteurs ?
Oui, ça, c'est une pratique déjà…
Oui, mais parfois, c'est peut-être encourager l'Église
à laisser un petit espace pour les visiteurs,
qu'ils puissent y aller,
parce que parfois, les anciens, même toi,
ils sont pris toujours les mêmes personnes
pour poser des questions, c'est légitime.
Oui.
Mais les visiteurs, peut-être,
n'ont pas la même opportunité.
Oui, je suis d'accord.
Il faut que ces conversations aient lieu au sein de l'Église.
Quand un diac, par exemple, s'approche d'une personne
qui est toujours là en train de parler au pasteur,
ou même les pasteurs disent ça,
mais de manière générale, par exemple, au moins moi,
quand je vois qu'il s'est un membre déjà de l'Église,
qu'il vient toujours, et c'est bien,
car parfois, il se sent appréciatif envers les messages,
il se sent des bonnes questions,
mais si jamais je vois un visiteur qui m'attend,
je fais exprès de couper et d'expliquer
que je dois donner l'attention à une autre personne.
Et cette compréhension doit être là.
Par contre, l'idéal, vraiment,
ça serait que géographiquement,
on soit plus accessible vers les schémas de sortie.
Ça, c'est la pratique de toutes les églises baptistes réformées
et même des églises réformées,
ou de la majorité au moins, ça devrait être.
Donc, par exemple, Lang Marx,
ils ont plusieurs sorties,
car c'est un grand bâtiment,
et il y a un pasteur dans chaque sortie
pour que les personnes soient saluées,
et les membres ont conscience
qu'ils doivent saluer assez vite.
Mais, des fois, il y a des membres
qui sont avec un problème un peu plus grave,
qui ont besoin tout simplement d'une prière,
et donc c'est l'occasion aussi de les faire.
Oui, Christian ?
Oui, dans le sens de la proposition de Joao,
je dirais que peut-être qu'on s'est fait
et c'est intéressant de voir
que les personnes encouragent
l'église surtout
à nous faire attention
au niveau de l'univers,
à ceux qui sont évités, par exemple.
Pour que l'église continue,
il faut toujours être senti là-bas.
Quand tout le monde est en train
qui sont évités,
qui voient un peu,
qui continuent à voir
comment Dieu travaille au milieu de nous,
cette joie, cette amour,
au sein des différences,
je pense que une personne qui fait ça,
dans ce sens,
ça sera encore mieux
que ce sentiment,
les enquêtes,
que ça repose sur eux.
Oui, en fait, c'est ça.
Je pense que la mise à disposition
des anciens est importante
au sein de l'église,
car les messages peuvent évoquer une réaction
et il faut que cela soit communiqué,
qu'il soit disponible,
peut-être en rappel pendant les annonces.
En même temps,
l'accueil, de manière générale,
et je pense que notre église,
elle vit bien ça.
Au moins, la réaction générale des visiteurs,
ils vont tous remarquer par rapport à ça.
Je pense qu'on fait un bon travail.
C'est quelque chose qui est une culture
qui a été développée,
ce n'était pas toujours comme ça.
Et c'est, à nouveau,
je reviens au travail
qui est toujours bien fait
et qui doit être toujours bien fait
dans les cours des membres,
dans les parcours des membres.
Mais je ne sais pas
si vous sentez les besoins aujourd'hui.
J'ai des renouvelés un peu plus
ces exhortations.
Mais moi, j'ai plutôt l'impression
que ça marche bien.
En général,
toutes les personnes qui vont finir
à désirer participer au cours des membres,
en général,
elles font des très bons retours
par rapport à la manière
dont ils ont été accueillis
au point de départ.
Et ça, c'est vraiment très beau.
En fait, par la fois,
ce que vous avez dit,
nous particulièrement,
on est très venus
à EDM,
la fête a été
vraiment particulière pour nous
parce que
parce que toutes les écoutes
qu'on a vues à l'école,
il n'y avait pas tout à fait.
On a des vies.
Et ça nous a beaucoup
aussi motivés
à revenir
à la fête de croire
et le Seigneur
qu'on vit.
mais...
Super.
Je pense qu'une chose
qu'on doit mieux travailler,
c'est d'agir
de manière plus intentionnelle
envers les déconnectés
qui sont membres.
Parfois,
des personnes plus
controversées,
ceux qui sont plus jeunes,
par exemple,
je pense à Hector,
je pense à certains jeunes
qui nous,
on devrait faire un peu plus
d'efforts
de les intégrer,
passer plus de temps
avec eux.
Ça fait partie
du ministère d'unité aussi,
du diacre,
la communion,
l'intégration,
tout ça.
Oui, parking.
Voilà,
donc,
un ministère des chauffeurs,
là,
même dans les livres,
ils évoquent ça.
Et imaginez,
ce sont des églises
qui ont un parking.
Et même là,
il y a des disputes,
car parfois,
il y a des occultes,
il y a des familles
qui devraient partir
plus tôt et ne partent pas,
il y a des confusions
dans les parkings.
Et il y a des diacres
là,
consacrés à ça.
Donc,
nous,
je pense que ça serait
important de les avoir,
surtout pour les pasteurs.
Il y a déjà une famille
très nombreuse
et ce n'est pas évident.
C'est déjà un problème.
Oui.
Mais c'est vrai.
C'est,
voilà,
c'est une solution
très pratique
pour permettre
que les personnes
soient là.
Si même les restos
ont ça,
comment une église
ne peut pas penser
à l'avoir ?
Et si jamais
il y a une résistance
par rapport à ça,
dans la culture,
j'aurais
j'aimerais en fait
comprendre pourquoi
en fait.
Car,
des fois,
la sensation c'est
pourquoi cette personne
pense qu'elle a
le droit
d'avoir ses services
et tous les autres
n'ont pas.
Ça semble être
un travail
très servissal.
Mais en réalité,
c'est l'esclave
qui doit faire
ce type de travail.
Et on veut faciliter
l'exposition des personnes
à l'église.
donc,
c'est notamment
pour ça
que les diacres existent.
Donc,
c'est un bon exemple
de ce qu'on doit faire.
Mais je ne sais pas
s'il y a des réticences
par rapport à ça
ou c'est juste quelque chose
qu'on n'a pas encore
trop réfléchi.
Tu parles du chauffeur là ?
Oui.
Personne qui va
garer la voiture.
Oui.
Il y a certains qui font
bien sûr
de manière très informelle
mais on est en train
de réfléchir
à mettre
à disposition
de l'église.
Oui.
Si quelqu'un
trouve de la difficulté
à trouver une place
donc mon beau frère
c'est sa responsabilité
à son église
en tant que diacre.
Les frères
de Mayra.
Et donc,
lui,
il doit arriver
un peu plus tôt
et il va rentrer
dans le culte
un peu plus tard
car il sera en train
d'égarer
les voitures
qui sont là.
Après,
c'est un peu
pour cette pratique
que je peux me permettre
il y a
la question
de la responsabilité
de la fragmentation
de l'assurance
en l'église
ici.
Oui.
Après,
est-ce que
par exemple
le côté intercède
nous avons
l'assurance
que tout le monde
est proposé
pour les voitures?
Ce n'est pas le cas
si il y a une assurance
particulière.
Oui.
Il va prendre l'assurance
pour tous les gars.
Je comprends
la préoccupation
mais à nouveau
dans l'environnement
familial
de l'église
si on devient
vraiment très
critérieux,
exagéré
sur certains points
donc là
on doit
s'assurer au moins
que les personnes
qui se disposent
à les faire
soient douées
pour les faire
qu'ils n'avaient
pas les permis
hier.
Mais
voilà,
je pense que
si on devient
très préoccupé
avec tous les détails
et toutes les implications
on ne va pas faire
grande chose.
Moi, je comprends
que pour les anciens
c'est désagré
mais pour toute l'église
on peut écrire
aussi des mauvaises habitudes
c'est-à-dire
la personne
ne se donne pas
l'habitude
d'arriver à l'ère
parce que là
il dit bon
moi je n'ai pas
la préoccupation
des chansons
parce qu'il y a des gens
qui vont me gagner
pour moi
mais ce sont des questions
plus faciles à régler
on va dire
par exemple
à partir de cette heure-là
c'est fini
et donc ça évite
mais il faut qu'on a
une heure
toujours
surtout
ceux qui sont
les plus nécessaires
dans les services
c'est-à-dire
les anciens
et les visiteurs.
Oui
mais au moins
on est à disposition
mais si nous sommes
à disposition
voilà
de manière appropriée
en faisant un peu
d'efforts
pour ressembler
à un chauffeur réel
peut-être qu'il voit
les sérieux
de ce qu'on fait
en fait.
Et on peut laisser
dans l'église
des chaises
peut-être des vents
et des chaises
dans meilleure place
entre guillemets
pour les visiteurs.
Oui
ça je suis complètement
d'accord.
Parfois
je n'ai jamais vu
mais peut-être
qu'il y a des visiteurs
qui restent débuts
au fond.
que les hommes diacres
soient toujours
prédisposés
à rester debout
et donner leur place
aussi aux visiteurs.
Aujourd'hui
c'est une culture
ça.
Oui
bien sûr.
On laisse toujours
l'espace pour les essais
de la chaises
voilà.
En fait il faut que
ça c'est quelque chose
qu'on peut déjà faire
aujourd'hui
il faut que
les personnes
qui placent
le matin
le sachent
et que s'ils viennent
nous voir
pour nous faire comprendre
qu'on devrait laisser
notre chaises
on soit disposé
il faut juste réserver
mettre des feuilles
réserver etc.
Non mais là
tu te projettes
dans une salle
non même là
on le somme
non aujourd'hui
on ne peut pas
laisser des chaises vides
elles se remplissent
tout de suite
mais par contre
s'il y a des visiteurs
qui viennent
les personnes
qui placent
il y en a toujours
le matin
qui regardent
où il y a des chaises
vides
quand il y en a
s'il y en a plus
et qu'il y a des visiteurs
ils peuvent venir
voir Joao
enfin n'importe
qui est ici
et faire comprendre
que
c'est bien
ok
il faut qu'on leur
dise qu'ils peuvent
faire ça
parce qu'aujourd'hui
je pense
ils cherchent juste
des chaises vides
pour le voir
les deux
Lucas et Lorenzo
si vous le entendez
je vous le dégage
c'est ça
vraiment pour un long
je suis
oui Claire
oui ça c'est une question
que j'ai répondu
qui je trouve très importante
je ne me rappelle plus
qui a posé la question
c'était toi
non Paul
oui
donc
la question
par exemple
est-ce que
tous les ministères
qui auront lieu
au sein de l'église
seront supervisés
par les diacres
ou
doivent avoir lieu
sous la supervision
des diacres
non
et pourquoi pas
car les diacres
n'ont pas les compétences
pour superviser
ils n'ont pas forcément
ou nécessairement
les compétences
pour superviser
des ministères
qui ne sont pas forcément
des services
donc un ministère
d'enseignement
comme le ministère
d'enfants
ou des écoles
des dimanches
ce sont des ministères
qui doivent être
supervisés directement
par les anciens
donc on n'a pas forcément
besoin
par exemple
des ministères
des groupes
des maisons
où on a
des personnes
qui ne sont pas
des anciens
mais qui sont en train
de conduire
et d'animer
le ministère
des enfants
c'est quoi concrètement ?
le ministère
des enfants
c'est un ministère
d'enseignement
oui mais concrètement
c'est quoi ?
par exemple
valider les EDM
qui sont dans
le ministère
de savoir
quel support
vous utilisez
par exemple
pour les
valider
ce qu'il fait
précisément
pour vous présenter
ce que vous pensez
mais il faut savoir
reconnaître aussi
que même pour
les ministères
des enfants
et même pour
l'école de dimanche
et d'autres projets
on a envie
de mieux structurer
de mieux aider
à conduire
nous on sait
reconnaître
en tant qu'équipe
pastorale
qu'on devrait
plus participer
à la structuration
de ces ministères
ok
mais pour l'instant
les minimaux
qu'on est en train
de faire à cet égard
c'est tout simplement
de valider
votre proposition
des programmes
pour les ministères
d'enfants
c'est la
supervision minimale
en fait
là
donc
voilà
ça c'est une question
qu'on a traité aussi
il y a des personnes
qui sont ici
qui
ont des évidences
d'appel
envers les diakonats
mais
il y a des personnes
qui ne sont pas ici
des femmes
qui ont plutôt
tout simplement
un appel
plutôt lié
à l'enseignement
et donc
dans les cas
des clercs
par exemple
c'est croisé
il y a les deux choses
qu'on peut percevoir
comme possibles appels
c'est clair
non pas forcément
à un moment donné
tu peux tout simplement
voilà
c'est ça
ce sont deux choses
que tu peux faire
voilà
par rapport à ta
voilà ta prédisposition
à servir
constamment
même
dans des airs
qui ne touche pas forcément
l'enseignement des enfants
et donc là
ça montre
un coeur diaconal
une prédisposition
à servir
par contre
quand on va traiter
hors cadre diaconal
la supervision
des ministères d'enseignement
et même par exemple
l'évangélisation
c'est pas un ministère
qui soit supervisé
ou coordonné
par les diacres
l'école du dimanche
même les études bibliques
même les groupes
des maisons
il y a beaucoup
des choses
qui
en termes
des supervisions
dépendent
directement
des anciens
car ça se porte
vers l'enseignement
les diacres
ils sont là
plutôt pour coordonner
ce qui est
service pratique
c'est clair là
la distinction
d'accord
et donc moi
je peux demander
à un diacre
de m'aider
à coordonner
la communication
avec les ministères
d'enseignement
ou d'enfants
elle peut m'aider
à faciliter
cette communication
mais c'est à moi
de superviser
ce qui est en train
de se passer
dans ces ministères
ok
oui
oui en fait
voilà on va arriver
oui
c'est ça
oui en fait
c'est
là où on veut arriver
c'est de fixer
dans nos agendas
des
voilà
des rendez-vous
réguliers
pour faire les points
avec tous les ministères
ok
on est dans une phase
moi particulièrement
très surchargée
notamment avec la famille
et les ministères
avec les priorités
des formations
d'anciens
etc
mais nous
en tant qu'équipe
pastorale
on doit faire
un mieux travail
dans la constance
et la régularité
des supervisions
des ministères
donc y compris
l'aide
que les diacs
vont apporter
mais aussi
ce qu'on doit
superviser directement
ok
donc ça c'est
les buts
oui
pour la conférence
est-ce que
l'équipe des diacs
par exemple
pour l'organisation
c'est une chose à part
ou c'est le même
c'est les diacs
on va dire
la classe ordonnée
des diacs
elle est là
à notre service
et l'expérience
des conférences
nous ont déjà donné
une idée
d'avec qui on peut compter
pourquoi
mais on n'a pas besoin
d'officialiser
les services
pour la conférence
liés au ministère
des diacres
l'organisation
de la conférence
c'est une question à part
même si nous allons
compter particulièrement
avec la prédisposition
des diacres
mais voilà
c'est juste une communication
qui doit avoir lieu
ici c'est tout simplement
une évaluation
de mon appel personnel
et futurement
une ordination officielle
pour que nous sachions tous
en tant qu'église
et des anciens
qui sont les personnes
avec qui on peut compter
avec plus de fiabilité
avec plus de prédispositions
à servir
qui sont les serviteurs
d'office
et là après
où on va les employer
ça va être un autre processus
bon pour certains
ou par la majorité même
ce sont déjà
des services
qu'ils font déjà
mais après
il faut aussi considérer
ces autres besoins
qu'on a devant nous
ok
il faut que j'avance
donc
processus d'évaluation
voici l'ordre des choses
comment elles vont se passer
la première chose
c'est les potentiels
identifiés
comment nous pouvons
identifier les potentiels
avant tout
et principalement
c'est un service
actif
informel
empiété
qui a déjà exercé
donc c'est là où par exemple
on a on vous a identifié la majorité
vous êtes déjà en train de servir
la majorité
avec un service constant
même si vous n'avez pas
les titres de diacre
d'accord
il y a donc
la perception pastorale
donc nous on échange
entre nous
on a évoqué
par exemple
on a organisé
chacun d'entre nous
à réfléchir pendant la semaine
pendant même plusieurs semaines
et chacun a porté une liste
et on a matché ces listes
des fois on a dit
oui je n'avais pas pensé
cette personne
c'est bien que tu l'as pensé
etc
et on est arrivé
à ce nombre
de possibles candidats
c'était pour identifier
les potentiels
ensuite
cela peut venir aussi
de la perception communautaire
peut-être que certains membres
de l'église
ou même vous
maintenant
pouvez dire
mais pourquoi
vous n'avez pas évoqué
telle personne
ou telle personne
car je vois clairement
les qualifications
l'appel
les capacités
elles servent déjà
etc
ok
donc si c'est une personne
qu'on n'a pas considéré
et qu'on devrait aller faire
c'est important pour nous
d'accueillir
car la communauté
participe aussi à ça
donc les apôtres
parlent à la communauté
et la communauté
amène
les candidats
ok
dans les passages
d'acte 6
et c'est plus ou moins
ce qu'on fait ici aussi
et donc
ensuite
il faut que la personne
aille
un niveau
suffisant
des convictions individuelles
et parfois
même si on n'est pas
venu vers elle
elle peut venir vers nous
et c'est l'une des tâches
les plus difficiles
des pasteurs parfois
dédiés
ou dédécouragés
dans les bons sens
donc on ne voit pas encore
d'évidence
suffisamment mature
pour que tu commences
à évaluer
c'est pas pour dire
que c'est impossible
mais parfois
la personne va partager
une conviction personnelle
et c'est à nous aussi
de l'enserrer
dans une évaluation
envers
la vocation
donc là
c'est la première partie
les potentiels identifiés
ainsi
ensuite la formation
théologique
car
comme nous tous
en tant qu'église
on devrait apprendre
à identifier un diacre
on a fait les cours
des diacres
et maintenant
aujourd'hui
on est en train de faire
d'une manière encore
plus intentionnelle
pour les candidats
potentiels
on est en train de faire
un séminaire
plus intensif
pour être sûr
qu'on a bien saisi
les choses
qu'on a révisé
il y a des emphases
que j'ai mis ici aujourd'hui
que je n'ai pas mis forcément
pendant les cours
pour toute l'église
car ça a un poids
plus important
des décisions
et des convictions
personnelles
de l'appel
ok
donc à partir de là
on fait
cette lecture du livre
pour démontrer aussi
votre responsabilité
dans cet engagement
et nous allons
à partir de maintenant
avoir quelques entretiens
pasto
avec vous
voilà
pour chercher
à discerner
de manière plus concrète
comment vous ressentez
l'appel
comment vous réagissez
ces cours
ces séminaires
cette possibilité
etc
et voir dans quelle
ère pratique
vous pouvez servir
ensuite
l'évaluation
pastorale
des qualifications
donc observation
et entretien
les évidences
de l'appel
les motivations
les convictions
bon
dans des conversations
qu'on aura
et les qualifications
qu'on a déjà
traversées
et ensuite
la période probatoire
pour attester
la constance
et l'excellence
et la fidélité
ici
la quatrième étape
on va vous envoyer
un formulaire
là c'est juste
la première version
qui sera révisée
par les anciens
mais c'est juste
pour donner
quelques exemples
des questions
que vous devez poser
à vous-même
et qui à l'occasion
de votre ordination
vos voeux
des consécrations
à ces ministères
se porteront
envers ces mêmes questions
on va formuler
les questions
différemment
plutôt
en forme
des veaux
des voeux
des serments
et donc
pour l'instant
ce sont les types
de questions
qui vous
devez vous poser
par rapport
à l'appel
en vous rappelant
qu'il y a
une dimension
des minimums
suffisants
et potentiel
grandissant
des fois
l'hésitation
peut nous empêcher
de vouloir répondre
positivement
à des questions
mais
après
par l'engagement
à s'exposer
à une évaluation
plus profonde
et plus pratique
peut-être
qu'on développe
de plus en plus
la conviction
vers la paix
c'est comme ça aussi
avec les anciens
qui par l'exercice
grandissent aussi
dans la conviction
d'avoir été appelé
à prêcher
l'évangile
et donc
avant les jours
de l'ordination
ces réponses
doivent être
répondues
positivement
avec plus de conviction
pour l'instant
même si c'est
embryonnaire
potentiel
il faut qu'elle soit
quand même
suffisant
c'est bon là
pour les questions
on va pas tout lire
mais
ce sont les questions
connectées
à l'appel
et vous allez remarquer
qu'il y a
une liaison
aussi
une continuité
avec l'engagement
de notre confession
des fois
de notre alliance
des membres
etc
ensuite
il y a
des questions
pour les qualifications
spirituelles
les évidences
de l'oeuvre
du Saint-Esprit
les qualifications
morales
relationnelles
les qualifications
familiales
et les vertus
particulières
à l'assistance
diaconale
aux femmes
ok
je sais pas
si vous voulez
un moment
pour essayer
de lire
vite fait
mais elle se porte
toutes sur
ce qu'on a déjà
réfléchi aujourd'hui
ok
les qualifications
fonctionnelles
donc il y a
aussi
ces calculs
concrets
combien d'heures
par semaine
puis j'ai raisonnablement
consacré au service
de l'église
sans négliger ma famille
mon travail
et ma santé
particulière
donc oeuvre
des miséricordes
support au ministère
des anciens
est-ce que j'ai
déjà mes dons
mes compétences
à service
qu'est-ce que je
pourrais mettre
encore à service
vous avez partagé
quelques idées
moi
moi j'ai aussi
un désir profond
voilà
que certaines
aires soient
plus développées
je reviens
à chaque fois
au ministère
des médias
les réseaux sociaux
je reviens
au site internet
je crois qu'aujourd'hui
ces choses
ont un grand potentiel
pour maximiser
notre service
car ça
rejoint
la notion
des publications
des diffusions
qu'on voit dans la bible
des transcriptions
ça renvoie aussi
à la notion
dans l'histoire
des publications
des livres
etc
c'est bon
et la résolution
et ça c'est pour exprimer
voilà une étape importante
ce formulaire sera en formulaire
d'évaluation
d'auto-évaluation
mais aussi en formulaire
des candidatures officielles
ok
c'est comme les fiançailles
avant les mariages
c'est à dire
quand on sait
la date
du mariage
on se sent plus
sur la pression
d'être à la hauteur
du défi
du mariage
et donc
c'est très important
pour nous
de savoir
que si on a encore
attention
à ce que je vais vous dire
si en ayant
traversé
ces séminaires
avec plus d'intensité
on a perçu
qu'on a été
oscillant
dans les passers récents
envers certaines attentes
pour être convaincu
de mon appel
je dois au moins
avoir été gêné
par le Saint-Esprit
et me dire
je vais mieux faire
j'essaierai plus constant
j'essaierai plus fidèle
et à partir de là
avoir cette opportunité
on va dire finale
entre guillemets
mais cette opportunité
d'une période probatoire
à partir du moment
où j'ai dit
oui
à ma candidature formelle
et la période probatoire
jusqu'au jour
de l'ordination
ok
et donc
c'est
c'est comme si on était
en train de
à partir de maintenant
faire une observation
encore plus
intense
voilà
de votre engagement
pour les services
et donc
ensuite on passe
à la période probatoire
donc il y a
un communiquat
de votre candidature
formelle
aux membres
de l'église
car eux
ils doivent aussi
participer
de manière consciente
à cette évaluation
un peu plus formelle
car l'ordination
s'approche
il y a déjà
une période probatoire
pour la majorité
d'entre vous
qui sont
à service
pendant longtemps
même
avant la formalisation
de cette candidature
il y a beaucoup
de personnes ici
par rapport auxquelles
on est déjà
convaincus
de l'appel
et qui ont déjà
été approuvés
par leur persévérance
mais il y en a
d'autres
dont on aura besoin
que cette période
probatoire
soit menée
d'une manière
encore plus sérieuse
ok
et ensuite
il y a
ces poids d'engagement
qui ont
qui ont croit
faire partie
de ce que Dieu
utilise
pour confirmer
votre appel
pour vous motiver
à servir
comme il faut
ensuite il y aura
la confirmation
pastorale
à la fin
de la période
probatoire
et nous allons
devoir
avoir déjà
une date envisagée
moi
je propose
je trouve
toujours beau
qu'une étape
importante
se passe
dans les cultes
de Noël
qu'on fait
et ça c'est une chose
qu'on va devoir
décider entre nous
l'équipe pastorale
trouver une date
mais le plus probablement
c'est vers la fin
de l'année
la date pour
l'ordination
ok
donc
en même temps
c'est important
de le dire
pour certains
qui sont déjà
en service
constant
envers qui
on a déjà
plus d'assurance
il y a beaucoup
plus de probabilités
que cela soit
confirmé
pour ces personnes
là
pour d'autres
c'est comme
j'ai dit aussi
pour les anciens
en formation
qui sont en train
d'évaluer
l'appel
il faut qu'ils soient
prêts aussi
pour entendre
notre préoccupation
en tant que pasteur
en tant que superviseur
c'est de protéger
l'église
de vous protéger
de ne pas vous mettre
dans une position
pour laquelle
vous êtes appelé
pour votre propre bien
et pour les biens
de l'église
et pour notre bien
car on sera
dévain devant Dieu
par rapport
à l'imposition
des manques
qu'on fait
envers les autres
et donc
si jamais
on
avec toute responsabilité
et amour
on vous décourage
pas encore
ou on n'est pas
convaincu
qu'on soit conscient
que c'est pour notre
propre bien
pour notre bien
personnel
pour les biens
de l'église
ok
et c'est aucun problème
ça ne les empêche pas
de servir
à l'église
ouais
aucun empêchement
pour servir
c'est juste
la reconnaissance
que
on n'a pas encore
ce qu'il faut
en termes de maturité
pour être officiellement
à service de l'église
ok
pourquoi
c'était quoi avant
période probatoire
là
et ensuite
c'est ça
attendez
je vais essayer
de mettre ça
ok
là c'est juste
un exemple
donc bien sûr
qu'on a enlevé
tous les noms
mais c'est un exemple
par exemple
de la manière
dont nous les anciens
on a évalué
quelques candidats
ok
si on peut
ou non
confirmer leur appel
les noms ont été évoqués
on a considéré
voilà
quelle est leur
occupation laïque
leur profession
et là
j'ai enlevé aussi
pour
pour difficulté davantage
les aires
qui nous on pense
qu'ils pourraient servir
et bien sûr
que vous devez participer
aussi
dans l'indication
de vos préférences
et donc
voilà
les critères
qu'on voit
qualification spirituelle
familial
relation
fonction
fidélité
et constance
y compris
présence assidue
dans les ministères
des prières
d'enseignement
public
et un rappel
des aires
que vous devez
voilà
prier
méditer
où j'aimerais servir
et donc
c'est un rappel
de ces aires là
des possibilités
mais
rien ne vous empêche
d'être encore plus
créatif
pour créer
de nouvelles opportunités
pour maximiser
les ministères
de l'église
ensuite
après cette période
probatoire
et l'évaluation
finale des anciens
la confirmation
des anciens
il y a
ce qu'on appelle
la nomination
pastorale
donc nous
les pasteurs
on va présenter
à l'église
maintenant
non seulement
ceux qui sont
en évaluation
mais notre avis
positif
envers ceux
qui ont été
confirmés
donc les membres
vont valider
normalement
c'est par les mêmes
échanges qu'on fait
par rapport
aux membres
sauf que là
il faut que ça soit fait
dans une assemblée générale
et qu'on ait
au moins
à mon avis
85%
d'approbation
dans
c'est varié
par rapport
aux propositions
des églises
différentes
mais
les plus importants
est l'office
c'est que la majorité
soit présente
on a l'impression
en acte 6
qui c'était
l'unanimité
ça a plu
toute l'assemblée
l'indication
qu'ils ont amené
et donc
c'est important
pour nous
de l'avoir
aussi
donc ça c'est
une proportion
qui nous allons
encore définir
mais
ça portera
beaucoup plus
vers l'unanimité
qui est tout simplement
la majorité
donc l'église
valider
les cultes
d'ordination
et c'est tout simplement
en liturgie appropriée
avec un message
approprié
les diacres
seront présentés
l'alliance des membres
sera rétablie
ou renouvelée
ensuite
des questions
seront posées
publiquement
aux candidats
envers
leur engagement
leur alliance
envers la communauté
pour servir
des voeux d'office
et la communauté
aussi
va accueillir
officiellement
en établissant
cette alliance
pour recevoir
leur office
et ensuite
l'imposition
des membres
est-ce que vous avez
des questions
jusque là
oui
les couleurs
c'est positif
ou négatif
oui
voilà
la situation familiale
traverse
une période
très difficile
les choses
ne vont pas très bien
donc on va mettre
la couleur convenable
je pense qu'on a
quatre couleurs
différentes
un peu comme
les feux
pour les circulations
de voiture
oui je sais
mais là
je pense qu'on a
quatre
juste pour avoir
un critère
en plus
mais en général
vert c'est plus
positif
voilà
et rouge
plus négatif
donc voilà
exercice et coordination
des ministères
donc là
on envisage déjà
la concrétisation
de ces choses
à nouveau
ça fait partie
de ces travails
d'organisation
de notre église
et on sait reconnaître
qu'il y a beaucoup de choses
qui manquent d'organisation
encore dans l'église
et là on pense
à la supervision
j'ai déjà plus ou moins
expliqué
donc les anciens
seront en train de
superviser
tous les ministères
voilà
il y aura des ministères
qui ne compteront pas
avec la coordination
des diacres
mais qui seront sous
la supervision
des anciens
mais les anciens
seront en train
de superviser
tous les ministères
diaconales
donc il y aura
beaucoup de libertés
pour que les diacres
travaillent
selon leurs services
mais à chaque
implémentation
des nouvelles idées
c'est important
de proposer
et passer
par l'évaluation
pastorale
ok
donc il y aura
un nombre variable
aussi
on va dire
une intensité variable
des proximités
du travail
des diacres
avec le travail
des anciens
ok
mais tout travail
diaconal
sera sous la supervision
des anciens
il y aura
par exemple
des travails
dans le secrétariat
qui sera plus proche
directement
du ministère
des anciens
mais
tous les ministères
diaconales
doivent être
sous la supervision
des anciens
on aura deux groupes
ok
séparés
voilà pourquoi
on a considéré
l'assistance diaconale
car il y aura
des ministères
qui sont plus appropriés
aux femmes
de les faire
et qui comptent
exclusivement
avec la présence
des femmes
et donc
elles n'ont pas
forcément besoin
d'être sous
la coordination
des anciens
hommes
ok
et donc il y a
cette possibilité
d'indépendance
à cet égard
mais à partir
du moment
où il y aura
des hommes
dans les groupes
féminins
c'est les hommes
qui vont être
à la tête
de cette coordination
ok
donc on a déjà
parlé sur ces choses
il y a cette coordination
et il y a aussi
la coordination
entre les ministères
individuels
et indépendants
donc c'est à dire
voilà
des personnes
qui sont
particulièrement douées
pour quelque chose
mais
ils ne sont pas
très nombreux
ce n'est pas une équipe
c'est une personne
qui est un diacre
et qui s'occupe
du bricolage
à l'église
et donc on peut
on peut tout simplement
tous faire appel
à son aide
à son service
peu importe
notre ministère
notre service
pour simplifier
un peu les choses
ok
est-ce que vous avez
des questions
par rapport à ça
j'ai pas compris
forcément la question
oui
en fait nous
on aime bien garder
la question
des
voilà
pouvoirs
partager entre nous
aussi la supervision
pastorale
donc même si
dans les tableaux
de l'église
que vous avez vu
il y a un pasteur
responsable
pour une aire spécifique
donc en général
les services
diaconales
seront retrouvés
sous
une de ces supervisions
et c'est ces pasteurs
là
qui sera
par exemple
si ça concerne
l'adoration
du dimanche
c'est Nat
qui a la supervision
des septaires
de notre église
et donc
les ministères
d'accueil
etc
seront sous
sa supervision
rangement de la salle
mise en place
etc
si c'est lié
plutôt à l'enseignement
même si c'est un support
pour les ministères
d'enseignement
c'est sous
ma supervision
d'accord
et donc
ça peut fonctionner
comme ça
mais rien
ne m'empêche
de demander à Nat
ou Loïc
voilà
d'exercer
une supervision
envers
un ministère spécifique
donc c'est
c'est l'équipe pastorale
qui dirige l'église
et donc
toute l'église
est soumise
quelque part
à leur direction
ok
est-ce qu'il y a des diacres
qui pourraient être
sous les responsables
par exemple
n'importe quoi
le ménage
est-ce qu'il peut y avoir
un responsable
qui ne soit pas
diacres
et des diacres
qui servent
dans le ménage
ça a pas son
je pense
ça a du sens
c'est possible
mais
voilà
ça sonne étrange
moi j'aurais préféré
qu'on ait
les diacres responsables
pas responsables
de tous les ministères
on peut avoir
des ministères
qui ne comptent pas
des diacres
et qui ont
des responsables
ça va dépendre
de comment on va
vous assigner
des tâches
pour que vous soyez
activement
en train de servir
dans une tâche particulière
afin d'être
au moins évalué
dans cette période
probatoire
ok
et donc
ce sont les prochaines
prochaines étapes
qu'on va faire
et on va vous communiquer
donc on va finir
avec
oui
ok
ça va
oui
d'accord
bon
on peut prier
ok
on va prier
pour toi
apparemment
il y a un truc
je ne sais pas
il a peut-être
manger quelque chose
d'accord
ok
on va prier
pour vous
ok
qui peut-je te bénisse
mon frère
qui peut prier
pour
Edouard
donc ici c'est juste
une dernière
considération
à propos
du poids solennel
et la crainte
qui doit s'emparer
sans ses privilèges
et crainte
et donc ce sont deux citations
une des bourgeons
notamment par rapport
aux anciens
mais comme il s'agit
d'un appel officiel
c'est important pour nous
de considérer
cette déclaration
et ici c'est très intéressant
donc dans la liturgie formelle
de l'église d'Angleterre
c'est très intéressant aussi
de rappeler
l'importance
de ne pas
oser
vouloir s'émettre
dans une position
pour laquelle on n'a pas
été appelé
à l'église
et donc
je voulais demander
à quelqu'un
de lire
d'abord les premiers
paragraphes
et après une autre personne
pour lire les deuxièmes
dans une autre personne
professeur dans le sens
des prophétiens
la foi
tout simplement
et ensuite
qui peut lire
cet autre là
pour
il est évident
que tout ce qui dit
avec prudigence
dans la salle de culture
et les anciens
que depuis le temps
des apôtres
il est dans les livres
et des livres
des ordres
et des ministres
évêques
prêtres
et des ordres
ces fonctions
ont toujours été tenues
en une
si révolant
celle-ci
que nul homme
ne pouvait prévenir
les dégâts
et ne l'auraient
d'abord appelé
et examiné
et reconnu
posséder
les qualités
et qu'il n'eut aussi
été
par la prière
république
et l'inclésion
d'un
approuvé
et admis
à ses fonctions
par une autorité
égique
c'est bien
voilà des questions
finales
oui
voilà ça c'est
l'église anglicaine
mais il y a
une base commune
donc nous
pour nous
ça c'est la même chose
eux ils font
la distinction
mais ça représente
bien l'esprit
réformé
et des puritants
par rapport
à l'importance
de s'assurer
de l'appel
et de ne pas
présumer
les exercer
sans avoir
la conviction
de l'appel
donc cette crante
qui est importante
pour les ministères
ok
17h01
c'est bien
bon
je vous remercie
énormément
de votre temps
consacré
je sais que c'était
long
intense
et
et on va
vous envoyer
ces formulaires
pour une évaluation
personnelle
en attendant
votre conversation
confirmation par rapport
à la candidature
et ensuite
fixer des entretiens
avec les candidats
et si jamais
vous avez des questions
vous avez encore
besoin d'aide
des réflexions
d'accompagnement
pastoral
on va se mettre
aussi à disposition
pour l'instant
on vous encouragerait
à faire
voilà
ces formulaires
et
et à partir de là
des entretiens
pour
définir
de manière très pratique
quels seraient
les services
auxquels
vous serez
engagés
peut-être
vous êtes déjà
engagés
pour cette période
probatoire
pour la